[Music]
hellish scenes after a helicopter
carrying Ukraine's interior Minister
crashed into a nursery
no one on board survived
a child on the ground was also killed
an investigation has been launched into
whether this was a tragic accident or a
deliberate Act of sabotage
either way Ukraine's president said
Russia's war is to blame
absolutely
the crash will be a personal blow for
Vladimir zielinsky killing the man on
the right interior Minister Dennis
monasterski
he's the most senior Ukrainian official
to die since Moscow launched its
full-scale War
Sky News met the minister last year when
he visited the scene of a suspected War
crime in the town of butcher how can you
talk to Vladimir Putin when his forces
do this go to hell
we also saw him months later again
risking his life out on the ground this
time in the city of isium after it was
liberated from Russian control from one
side I I'm happy just now
but from Another Side I am not upset
because many our Ukrainian citizens I
mean civilians we found here and they
did by Russians the 42 year old's death
Drew tributes from colleagues in Ukraine
and across the world it's a young guy
very patriotic guy do it a lot of things
for Ukraine
is
um
the crash also killed the deputy
interior Minister and other officials
a devastating loss
ukulele at a time of War
debraham Sky News